the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
we have a group of two or three Comm
gravis
and your solar cells from me and she was
like somewhere in this room to work
we're just we're staying here for us do
you want to overlay oh you know you're
not actually soldering directly yeah you
don't want overlay okay so these three
fun there's our halloween yeah so you
generally want to go look the way you
would generally delivery so much so I
think it's less critical that you cover
this entire set so you cover a little
bit of its honor to that and the back is
also like all dis is conductive the only
reason the tabs are there are because
the tabs or resource other two and so
just get more convenient and you don't
really need to solder to all of them
individually you can only sound like ad
minimal if you want it to sound like
doing really literally you could just do
like a solder from a wire from there to
there and that would work like that be
fine but the reason that they have a lot
of them is because if something tracks
or something like that and you can't
tell if you have a wire running across
your wires on crack because these are
fragile and so you have more you also
have more context see your your you can
you should feel free to wire it however
you want we're going to test a murder
it is enough yeah we write what you want
to sit in a lot of small shows I'm
trying I'm trying to think if I was work
you but I don't know like I don't know
if that would work it'd be a false okay
yeah but I don't know if you can do that
across a specific so i could feel like
that wouldn't work because i mean it
would definitely make sense if you took
two of them and you did one one way and
you did right was that you had them
going in two different patterns on one
side so you're connecting positive to
negative to positive to negative haha
and then on the other one you were
expecting negative to positive negative
to positive yeah less on top yeah tub
right yeah
yeah II i'll tell you a traditional idea
now let's go
yeah it's a good did you decide you so
you should also probably have this
shorter because this is electrically
conductive even like even though it's
not tab it like the entire surface and
like you conductive if it's touching
this in a short so like this part like
you only need this mental / is always I
know well that is true so the thing is
that all of these are like this is all
one surface that's electrically
conductive the tabs are just there to
make it easier to solder onto or
supposedly make it easier to solder onto
but the thing is that if you have two of
these like right next to each other and
they're like three facts like there's a
lot of touch them like this wire is
touching this then you're going to short
you're okay okay yeah so there's an
apartment all you need to do is from
here like this much
narsimha crack
you
these are really pretty in the Sun the
ass on your chicken voltage you need to
like sort of do it in parallel I took it
across an element to see how much
voltage is being dropped
so in this circuit the only so you have
this like battery this is the
the only load is and so this is going to
be dropping all of the voltage that
being collected by this by this
and I think this is good
you don't have any 2.36
that's a lie a mess hold everything
you don't
yeah because this becomes this
difference like the finishing oh so in
that case we are we not on we're going
to stop yeah we'll take the voltage
across this mine
excellent nice work whimpers wait 580
supple so I'm what was the resistance
hundred ohms
it should take it just just go inside
yeah switch all those three numbers I
don't think we ever joy in the way to
cover are we going to do you want to
just cover that because all the greater
handle to the first time you didn't
execute a sure let's do that we just
covered one
entire cell
75 right
sure